Oh, man, this galaxy that we just found with JWST is
13 billion light years away. No, it isn't.
Or is it?
Maybe at some point,
but not when that light left and not one when it has arrived.
[Intro Music]
Hey, crazies. Welcome to another installment of Wife Reacts.
This is my wife, Awkward M.
Hello!
Okay, so how familiar are you with how we measure distances in space?
Oh, I'm not at all familiar.
At all.
No.
Okay.
If you wanted to measure the length of something, what would you do?
I would grab some kind of measuring tool.
So, like a tape measure or a ruler or something?
Yes.
What about if the distance was just a little bit longer, like maybe Detroit to Chicago?
I would use Google Maps for sure.
Okay.
What if the distance is so far away
that we don't have access to the other end of the trip?
Do you mean we don't have access like it's in the middle of the ocean and you can't drive that far?
Or like...
No, because then you could still use a boat and get there.
Okay.
Right. I'm talking like Mars.
What do you do?
What do you do if you want to figure out what the distance to Mars is and you can't go there.
Thankfully, in the last little bit, we have gone there a couple of times, at least with probes and stuff.
So...
Do probes have odometers?
Say it's 1920.
And we don't have any space program yet.
There's no such thing as a space probe.
Haven't even been to the moon.
Right.
How do you figure out the distance to the Moon or to Mars or to Saturn or to other stars in the universe?
You don't. No I'm just kidding, I have no idea.
Well, this is a problem that scientists, astronomers were facing that we've been facing for a long time.
Sure.
We're going to do this in stages.
Each of these techniques represents a rung in something we call the distance ladder.
So the techniques kind of stack on top of each other.
Right.
We use one technique to calibrate the next.
And then use it to stretch across the next gap.
And so as we move forward, we're going to get into larger and larger distances from Earth.
Sure.
[Transition Music]
First off, we have something we call radar ranging.
Radar itself, the word “radar” is actually an acronym.
It stands for radio detection and ranging.
And so if you say radar ranging, you're basically saying radio detection and ranging ranging.
Well, this is what we do in our language, though. So here we are.
Right.
But basically, the idea is that we can send some kind of radio signal out, it’ll reflect off of something and come back.
In that case, you might be thinking like we're sending it out to some space probe we sent out and we're bouncing it back, which does happen.
But we were able to do this before that.
Which means you're actually bouncing it off of an object.
Right.
So radar was invented in the, like, early to mid-thirties by a handful of countries, almost like, simultaneously.
It was one of those things that, like, it was time.
Right.
Historically speaking.
We were ready for it, and everyone just kind of happened on it all at once.
Sure.
I'm comfortable with that.
Right.
Now, we didn’t actually use it for astronomy until the forties, like the mid to late forties.
When someone thought, You know what? What if I try to reflect a radio signal off the moon?
And so they sent a signal straight to the moon, and it bounced off and came back, and they picked up the signal.
Wow.
Yeah.
That must have been exciting.
It's a big deal.
Yeah.
But even that, reflecting the signal off the moon is kind of a pain when you're just reflecting it off of moon rock.
Sure.
So in the sixties, the late sixties, when we finally landed on the moon, we were able to put a reflector down.
I imagine it would have to be pretty big, or else your instruments would have to be very specific.
I'm guessing maybe something like this.
It's a pretty precise instrument that's going to be able to hit that, right?
Right.
But it gives us a much more accurate measurement of the distance to the moon.
And that's how we know that it's, you know, exactly so many miles or kilometers up there.
Sure.
The furthest we've ever been able to measure with this method is Saturn.
Which is pretty far!
It is pretty far.
It has to go all the way to Saturn and then come all the way back
before we actually receive it.
Which makes it remarkable that we even made it to Saturn to begin with.
Right.
We have this thing called the inverse square law. Have you ever heard of the inverse square law?
Yeah. I have heard of it for sure. Do I remember what it is? It's like as it goes... As light goes out, it becomes dimmer.
Right.
Is the gist right?
Yes.
Just imagine a light pulse for a moment.
And that pulse, you turn a light on and you turn back off.
That light energy is going to be distributed over a sphere.
And as the sphere gets bigger, the energy kind of thins out.
It gets thinner and thinner and thinner.
So as light goes out, it gets dimmer, ya?
Right, yes.
That change can get real dramatic real fast.
And so this has its limits.
[Transition Music]
So you're a biologist.
I am.
You know how we have binocular vision, right?
Yes.
We have two eyes which allow us to see, you know, some semblance of depth.
Human eyes are anywhere from like 2 to 3 inches apart.
It's like 5 to 8 centimeters.
Okay.
This gives us two different images that our brain kind of parses out.
Right. Because brains are wild.
Right.
There's a discrepancy in where an object is based on how close it is to you.
So if you look with one eye versus looking with the other eye,
the object actually shifts back and forth.
And the closer it is to you, the more it shifts.
Sure.
For human eyes, this works out to, say, 65 feet or 20 meters.
We get pretty good depth perception out to that far.
After that, it starts to falter a little bit, things are a little too close together in the two images for our brains to parse out how far away they are.
So we can take advantage of this binocular vision method astronomically.
But we need a much larger spacing between the images.
Okay.
Between the eyes.
Sure.
It's called stellar parallax.
This method has been around for a very long time.
And so it's considered sort of the foundation of the cosmic distance ladder.
Okay.
We take a picture of a star, and then we wait six months, and we take another picture of the star.
Those eyes are very far apart.
Yes.
I thought they were just going to be in different spots on the Earth.
No, no. The entire diameter of Earth's orbit.
Okay.
On average.
And so essentially what you get is something like this.
The Earth goes around the Sun, right, in its orbit.
And so it looks like the star is wobbling against the background stars.
Right? At one point in the year it's here against those stars.
And then another point, it looks like it's over there.
And so what we do is we take those pictures and then we can measure an angle between the two images.
We've been really good at measuring angles in the sky for thousands of years.
Sure.
And we've been trying to use them to calculate distances for all of that time.
Props.
Yes.
So we essentially figure out what this angle is,
and then we just use trig to figure out the lengths of the triangles
because we know what the diameter of Earth's orbit is.
And so then we should be able to get the other leg of the triangle.
Yeah, that's high school math.
Right.
This was the leading way to measure distances to stars.
Okay.
It just takes a long time.
It does. You have to do a lot of waiting.
Right.
This also has range limits.
Now, these range limits have gotten better over time as our technology has gotten better.
Now we have something called the Gaia space probe.
I've heard of Gaia.
I’m trying to remember what video was I looking up stuff for.
It was the black hole video.
Oh, that was it.
Yeah.
You're right.
Gaia BH1 and Gaia BH2.
That's it.
Gaia does a lot of stellar observation.
But it's really good at doing stellar parallax.
It is so sensitive that it has allowed us to measure distances out to about 30,000 light years,
which is a huge portion of our own galaxy.
Our galaxy's about 100,000 light years across.
And so almost a third of the galaxy
just with parallax, which means those numbers are solid.
Okay.
The farther the star gets from Earth, from our Sun ...
The smaller the angle is going to be.
Yeah, exactly. The smaller the angle gets.
The smaller it gets, the harder it is to measure.
Back in like 1920ish,
the distance we could measure parallax out to was only about 300 light years.
Which is still, you know ...
It's still a lot,
but it's a tiny, itty bitty fraction of our own galaxy.
If you talk to some of the astronomers back then,
they might have only trusted the distances out to like 200 light years.
Okay.
300 was pushing it.
Sure.
Some scientists said that they could do up to 300.
Right.
Some very ...
The young ones.
The old ones were like, no way.
Stay in your lane, kid.
[Transition Music]
Once you need to step beyond parallax,
we take advantage of the problem we ran into with radar ranging.
The inverse square law.
Yes.
And we can measure a star's apparent brightness to us.
That's easy to do.
Okay.
This is where the standard candles come in?
Yes.
Oh, no.
The trick is, we also need to know what its actual brightness is.
And how could you possibly?
Right.
That's tough.
But we can in some circumstances, which is awesome.
So here's what it feels like.
It feels like you need to know what the actual brightness is in order to figure out how far away it is.
But it also feels like you would need to know how far away it is
in order to know how bright it actually is.
For most stars, yes, that's true, but not for all of them.
Do tell about these specialty stars.
We had been looking for standard candles for a long time.
I think that first things first, you need to tell us what a standard candle is.
Well, I mean... you pretty much... Yeah. Okay.
A standard candle is essentially a bright object, usually a star,
that can be used as a standard for measuring distance.
And so that's why we call it a standard candle.
It's a very descriptive name.
Could be more descriptive if you called it a standard star.
Right.
The thing is that back in the day,
brightness was measured in terms of candles.
Okay. Stars still existed back in the day.
It's not like this is a new thing that's popped up all of a sudden.
We actually have this brightness unit
which is based on candles and like what the brightness of a candle would be from one meter away or something.
Candles were a big deal.
Candles were kind of the standard for what brightness was.
The standard standard candle?
Right.
And so when we got to astronomy,
it just kind of got used as a metaphor.
Okay.
I don't get to name these things.
That's on you.
So the trick is to find an object that you can measure something about to determine its actual brightness.
We have actual brightness and apparent brightness.
We could take advantage of the inverse square law as long as we have both of these numbers.
How can you have both of these numbers without knowing how far away it is?
That's a very good question.
[Transition Music]
There was this type of star that had been known about for a while.
They're called Cepheid variables.
These stars seemed to vary in brightness over time.
Usually it's anywhere from, like, 10 to 20 days.
So, like, we don't have to wait six months for this thing. We just have to wait a couple of weeks.
And so we can monitor the brightness of these stars.
And the brightness seems to vary.
It gets bright and dim and bright and dim.
The period of the cycle in brightness is directly related to their actual brightness.
And so if they were a brighter star, then the cycle would be a particular period.
And if it was a dimmer star, it would be a different period.
You could actually take the period of this brightness cycle
and calculate a peak brightness. It’s not an apparent brightness.
An actual brightness.
We found a lot of these Cephied variables within the range that parallax worked.
Interesting.
So this is how the rungs are stacking on top of each other.
Right.
So we were able to know how far away those stars were and use that information to calibrate the Cephied variable cycle.
But Cepheid variables are resolvable out to about a hundred million light years.
Whoa.
We're not just talking the distances to stars or clusters of stars within our own galaxy.
We're talking other galaxies.
Definitely.
Which we didn't even know existed at the time.
Yeah. Far, far away.
Far, far away from the docks.
Yes. Ahoy.
Ahoy.
And like I said, these things only work out to about 100 million light years
and not because we have trouble measuring the brightness,
but because we have trouble resolving individual stars.
Okay.
And 100 million light years gets us quite a way.
It covers basically our entire cluster that we're in, our entire galactic cluster.
Our neighborhood.
Right.
Not our star neighborhood, but our galaxy neighborhood.
Yes, Our galactic neighborhood.
Yes.
[Transition Music]
We would like to measure things beyond 100 million light years.
Never satisfied.
Right.
And so we have another really good standard candle
called a Type 1a supernova.
Those are bright.
Stars tend to form in binary systems,
our Sun is kind of an exception to the rule.
We're kind of a weird star system.
A lot of the time,
one of those stars is a little bigger, and it gets to the end of its life before the other one does.
And it will form a white dwarf if the stars are small enough, the stars are like our Sun.
The thing about white dwarfs is that they are a stellar remnant,
and stellar remnants are only stable up
to a very, very specific mass value.
In the case of white dwarfs, that is 1.4 solar masses.
That was what your thesis was, right?
Yes.
Let's say a white dwarf formed in a binary system. The other star is still a star.
And it starts to siphon mass, siphon material off of its companion.
Which one?
The white dwarf starts to suck mass off of its companion.
Okay.
Eventually, the mass of the white dwarf is going to grow to 1.4 solar masses
and it's going to collapse on itself.
We're going to make a black hole?
If anything survives, it'll make a neutron star. But usually nothing survives.
The explosion is too dramatic.
Okay.
And so what happens is it collects enough mass.
It hits that number, that 1.4 solar masses, and collapses and explodes.
And because they always blow up at 1.4 solar masses,
we know exactly how bright that explosion is supposed to be. Okay.
How long are ... Like, what kind of time scale are we talking about here? Do you know?
My guess would be days?
Okay. Okay.
When you're talking about stellar stuff
I don’t know, the time scale can be very long.
Right.
They are well within, you know, a human lifetime.
Okay.
We began to find some of these within the 100 million light years that the Cephied variables worked.
And so we were able use the Cephied variables to calibrate the Type 1a supernova.
Sure, sure.
And because Type 1a supernovas are so bright, we can see them out much, much farther.
We're looking at 3 billion light years.
And so we have the next rung on the ladder.
Sure, sure.
[Transition Music]
Once we're beyond the range of Type 1a supernovas, we have to use redshift.
It's the only ... I was wondering if that was going to play a part in this.
It's the only thing that we have left.
But because some redshift is measurable within the range of Type 1a supernovas,
we can use the Type 1a supernovas to calibrate the redshift for distance.
And so now we have our last rung on the ladder.
In fact, there are some distances within the range where redshift is the only thing that works.
Where it doesn't even make sense anymore to mention a distance in parsecs or light years.
Because it's just so far.
It's so far away that we end up with significant ambiguity
about what the word distance even means.
That's absurd.
That doesn't even make sense.
Not only does it become model dependent.
But depending on what kind of distance you want.
Do you want, proper distance, the distance that they currently are?
Or do you want the distance that they were in the past
or the distance that the light traveled? They’re all different.
So at that point, do you just say that it is far, far away?
You just say that it's a redshift of eight.
You just quote the redshift and move on.
And that means something to some people.
We have given up because the redshift is what matters anyway at that distance.
Okay.
So why bother coming up with a light years distance?
Well, because we like to know how far away things are.
Because we like to know.
And so whenever you hear something ...
Oh, man, this galaxy that we just found with JWST is 13 billion light years away. No, it isn't.
Or is it?
Nobody knows, apparently.
That is the distance that the light traveled to get here.
Okay.
It traveled 13 billion light years to get to Earth from where that galaxy was when the light left.
And so since then, it has expanded away from us for 13 billion years.
Right.
And it is now much farther.
It is now much farther away.
And we can use models to determine how far away it currently is.
But that is model dependent, and so maybe not all that useful.
And the light is what we're analyzing anyway.
Sure.
We might as well quote the number that the light traveled.
That specific galaxy at that specific time was that far away.
No.
No!?
It was a lot closer than that.
What? Because expansion.
Yeah.
Because remember, the light was traveling, the light was traveling for 13 billion years.
You’re right. You're right.
And so it had to, the light had to travel a lot farther than that galaxy was 13 billion years ago.
Space expanded.
Because space expanded.
How frustrating for that light.
It's so annoying.
That light is like I'm just trying to get to the place.
And in space just keeps expanding and fighting its travel.
And so when we say that this galaxy is 13 billion light years away,
maybe at some point,
but not when that light left and not one when it has arrived.
But you have to be able to communicate it somehow.
Right.
This is information that has to be able to be communicated.
If you're trying to communicate it to a non-scientist saying, well, Z equals six,
that doesn't mean anything to anybody.
Yeah. It's far, far, far away.
Yeah.
Far, far away.
So far away that distance doesn't even make sense.
Right.
But this is the best we can do for you.
And it's going to be farther away than something that is, whose light has been traveling for less time.
Correct.
We have relative distances. Communication can occur.
Yes.
[Transition Music]
If we bring this back to the beginning, right?
When we talk about when we measure length, we want to measuring device.
We need access to both ends.
We don't really have that with astronomy.
We have to be creative. We have to use all these different techniques
where we're measuring something else and then inferring a distance based on what we know about physics.
Right.
And it doesn't mean that those distances are wrong.
It just means that we're not technically measuring distance.
Ultimately, we get to really far away things.
And it doesn't even make sense to talk about distance anymore.
You just start talking about something else instead.
Right.
That also allows you to infer how far away something is.
In the end we don't measure distance.
We measure something else like time. And we infer distance.
I mean, honestly, this is something that we do in our daily lives anyway.
How far is it to thus and such?
20 minutes.
Right.
We already do this.
This is very natural for us.
Right.
And so this isn't that much of a stretch and it isn't any reason to like, question the cosmic distance ladder.
We've been developing this thing for a century.
Over a century.
And it's really solid.
Okay.
I'm just going to sneak in here for a minute
to let you know the next Science Asylum video is already on Nebula.
It's all about the fact that you can't tell the difference
between being in an accelerating rocket versus standing on Earth
and how that led to a deeper understanding of gravity.
This is going to be hilarious.
Where do you think you are, man?
Well, I can't tell exactly, but I feel my weight against the floor,
so I'm going to guess this room is somewhere on Earth?
Nebula is a creator-owned streaming service
with a mission to empower those creators.
Everything is completely ad and sponsor free,
which honestly, is how all videos are meant to be experienced.
They have a wide selection of content and it's stuff I actually watch:
Joe Scott, Up and Atom, Uno Dose of Trace, and more.
The Science Asylum is there too, including our next video weeks early.
If you sign up for Nebula using my link below,
you'll get access to that video right now.
You'll also get a huge discount, 40% off.
That's only $2.50 a month for the annual plan.
30 bucks gets you everything on Nebula for a year.
And on that note, let's get back to the cosmic distance ladder.
Whew! We climbed the ladder.
Right!
Got all the way up.
All the way up.
It's quite a ways.
Yeah.
Well, on that note.
Until next time, remember:
It's okay to be a little crazy.
Many of you pointed out in the last video
that it's odd for NASA to name a telescope after an administrator.
And you know what? That's fair. It's an unusual choice.
If it were me, I probably would have chosen a scientist.
But the point I was trying to make in that video
is that the name wasn't offensive. Anyway, thanks for watching!